où l'on reparle de l'aéroport
international n'en prenne ce projet qui
semblait aux oubliettes vient de
ressurgir orange élément nouveau une
volonté commune des deux présidents des
conseils généraux d'ille et vilaine et
de loire-atlantique de mener à son terme
le projet de notre dame des landes mais
l'horizon reste lointain on parle des
années 2025 ou 2030 il y a trois mois
châteaubourg devenu aéroport
international de nantes atlantique
la nouvelle aérogare était inaugurée
preuve de l'extension du premier
aéroport de l'ouest avec un million de
passagers en un an
château de bourgon est le huitième en
france 100 millions de francs
d'investissements ont été réalisés
depuis 1987 pour le développement de son
trafic international
mais à l'horizon 2028 nantes atlantique
sera probablement saturé avec un trafic
de 4 millions de passagers
d'où la nécessité d'une nouvelle
plateforme il s'agit pas de concurrencer
dans atlantic bien entendu mais de tenir
compte de l'évolution du trafic
deuxième millénaire est d'être prêt à
répondre dans le cadre de l'arc
atlantique un grand aéroport recouvre
encore une fois deux régions voire plus
depuis 15 ans le département de loire
atlantique constitue une réserve
foncière à notre dame des landes ainsi
nettement plus proche de nantes que de
rennes
pourtant l'île et vilaine avait déjà
apporté son soutien au projet l'an passé
pierre méhaignerie est en effet
favorable un aéroport du grand ouest
dans la perspective de l'arc atlantique
même arène ce vieux projet vu d'un oeil
favorable par la chambre de commerce
l'aéroport de saint jacques n'a pas de
réelle vocation internationale
à mon sens cet aéroport devrait être un
point de départ d'un grand pôle
d'affaires entre rennes et nantes ou
aéroport international mais
nécessairement garde éclatement tgv mais
également pôle d'affaires c'est-à-dire
des mureaux c'est à dire du tertiaire
ceux ci auraient un rôle s'ils voulaient
au niveau de l'aménagement du territoire
et de la dynamique du grand ouest
européen très important en fait
l'aéroport et n'est plus perturbé
actuellement par la concurrence du tgv
que par la perspective lointaine d'un
nouvel aéroport au nord de nantes une
plateforme de dimension européenne qui
pourrait voir le jour dès l'an 2000 si
les autres collectivités suivent